from lethal workouts to secret beck hat
tips you season 3 is packed with tons of
sneaky easter eggs call backs and pop
culture references yipikai movie lovers
i'm jan and in this video i'm revealing
40 killer details you might have missed
in season three of you spoilers ahead so
take care if you're not caught up
when joe becomes obsessed with his
neighbor natalie as we see him go off to
snoop on her he grabs his old trusty
stalking cap which has been placed on
top of an earnest hemingway biography a
nod to how he dressed up as the famous
author for beck's birthday party in
season one why are you wearing a
turtleneck i'm hemingway and it's also a
hat tip to how the author came up during
one of the dates joe went on to make
love jealous in season two you know
you're hemingway very sexy the seed for
joe's decision to get away from love and
take henry with him is planted in his
mind during his conversation with
natalie who comments that kids aren't
handcuffs it's a neat little remark that
calls back to the literal handcuffs that
joe almost killed love with in the
season 2 finale just before she blurted
out that she was pregnant with his child
stopping him in his tracks he is the
only reason
i'm alive while joe is creepily stalking
natalie at the library he stood right
next to a stand of scott landon books a
wicked reference to the stephen king
novel lisey's story which features a
stalker harassing the wife of author
scott landon
after joe murders marienne's ex-husband
ryan as he walks away from the crime
scene he sarcastically comments always
stay through shavasana a humorously dark
reference to the yoga position commonly
known as a corpse pose which involves
lying like a dead body on your back
which is how ryan ends up right outside
a yoga studio
when joe and marien discover they shared
a similar childhood as they were both
abandoned by their parents a connection
between the pair begins to form the
beginning of their illicit relationship
is also signaled by the fact they're
standing next to a book titled truly
madly guilty
as joe tries to keep his marriage with
love on an even enough kill that she
doesn't find out about marianne and kill
her he gets his wife a present of an
expensive casserole dish he's been
looking for and it's also filled with
doughnut pal this is a throwback to
season two when joe missed out on a trip
for that same fresh strawberry and
cream-filled dessert with love the
things that this donut shop does with
fresh strawberries should be considered
a sex crime and they were also the same
donuts that milo got for love when she
and joe broke up
when love's mum dottie drunkenly rolls
up for some mexican food the place she
goes to is called tacos de la madre
which translates literally from spanish
as mother's tacos the choice of that
particular food for her and henry
certainly isn't a coincidence either
because dottie believes that love's baby
is 40 reincarnated and in both the tv
show and original books 40 is addicted
to taco bell and of course dottie like
40 was on a bender in that moment in the
show herself he's the reincarnation of
my son 40 and he loves a good taco don't
you baby the name of the fictional town
where love and jo live madre linda also
reflects season 3's emphasis on
motherhood in spanish it means lovely or
beautiful or wonderful mother a
reference to how after moving there love
initially finds herself struggling to
fit in with seemingly perfect mothers
like sherry a successful mum fluencer
joe describes madre linda as the safest
neighborhood in california at the
beginning but ironically by the end it's
become notorious for multiple gruesome
murders and kidnappings all supposedly
committed by the town's new less than
perfect mother love
a new character in season three is theo
who has a touch of joe about him with
his feminist pretenses and somewhat
obsessive romantic pining and pushy
gestures towards love similar to joe
theo imitates iconic romantic movie
moments such as the scene from the 80s
movie say anything where john cusack
holds up a boom box to prove his love
according to all the rom-coms of your
generation this is what the guys are
supposed to do to get the girl what theo
didn't realize though is that love just
isn't that kind of girl i hate rom-coms
take away my ovaries in the penultimate
episode after theo figures out joe was
driving natalie's car the day she
disappeared he goes on to discover that
the conrads are currently locked up in
the basement of love's bakery it's at
this point we get to see the expand your
mind t-shirt he's been wearing a nod
perhaps to what a mind-blowing
experience all these discoveries have
been for theo
when sherry and carrie eventually find
the key that love hidden the cage it
turns out it was hidden inside a tub of
vanilla powder an ironic little detail
given what sherry called love and joe
just before she started looking those
two face vanilla businesses notice also
that the brand's name on the tub is
french le mayo which means the best
fitting given loves perfectionism when
it comes to cooking it's the best bakery
in town shotty lamination definitely
didn't use french butter both joe and
beck mocked the affectionate term babe
in the first season you said babe was a
default for unimaginative lovers and
love also hated the term when milo used
it with her in the second season if you
call me babe again i'm sticking on the
oven so it's more than coincidence that
when sherry and carrie arrive for the
swinging session with german love they
start using the term with each other
okay but i'm all over it making it a
little signal on top of the many others
of how the conrads are really worlds
apart from the quinn goldbergs these
people are so much more effective than i
thought youth writers have a bit of fun
with the dramatic trope of chekhov's gun
when joe discovers that carrie brought a
gun to the swinging session this is a
chekhov situation now isn't it if i
touch it i all but guarantee it gets
fired the trope is fulfilled when love
gives it to the conrads who end up using
it twice don't get hysterical i took a
seminar
leaving joe regretting not having it
himself when he's getting beaten up by
ryan neutral wishing you had chekhov's
gun to fire the use of the trope in
season three also calls back to the
second season when forty drunkenly
explained his feature film idea at
henderson's party it's chekhov's knife
and as soon as we see it we know throats
are gonna get cut forty of course was
right because when we saw love expertly
using a knife to butcher a piece of meat
early in the second season it was a big
clue to the twist that she'd be revealed
as a knife slashing serial killer
similar to joe
joe and love's distrust of each other
comes to a head in their last meal
together when love cooks him a roast
chicken a call back to when they first
met and she took joe on a culinary tour
of la in search of his favorite food
which ended up being the roast chicken
she cooked for him that night perfect
bite perfect the idea of joe's perfect
bite also came up in season three when
he was feeling guilty about love making
him delicious food while he was thinking
about marianne perfectly ready i don't
think it's a coincidence that in the
library scene where joe thinks marianne
is starting to flirt with him she's also
putting away a book with the title
vessel a signal that she's about to
become yet another vessel for joe to
project his fantasies onto his latest
you the next in his parade of
replaceable interchangeable women from
candace to beck love and natalie who he
can obsess over and fill with his
idealized view of what a perfect woman
should be and toss aside when they don't
meet his manufactured version of them
joe's warped opinion of himself as a
good man a hero even comes up when he
compares himself to the fictional
character atticus finch from the
pulitzer prize-winning book to kill a
mockingbird you're a steady stalwart
atticus finch this idea is reinforced
later on when love's mother dotty says
that joe looks like a young gregory peck
the actor who played finch in the 1962
adaptation of the novel
marienne however makes a much less
flattering comparison when she makes fun
of joe's look as he arrives at work
after a photo shoot with sherry whole
vibes very
patrick bateman meets venetian gondola
marianne is on the money of course in
comparing joe to the fictional serial
killer and unreliable narrator from
american psycho and later on in the
finale she reveals she did have her
suspicions about him when love is
thinking about having a second baby with
joe a daughter she hopes she seems to
settle on the name julia which is
interesting as marienne's daughter is
called juliet which means little julia
of course joe's name begins with a j2
and in a flashback we also discovered
that joe's mother had a new son called
jacob after she gave joe up perhaps like
joe's mother then love is subconsciously
trying to replace juliet the daughter of
his new obsession with her own little
girl
a shout out to a liar who noticed that
when joe takes on the pseudonym nick at
the very end it's likely a reference to
nick carraway from the great gatsby
similar to joe nick is the narrator and
a character in f scott fitzgerald's
famous novel and there've been many
other great gatsby references through
the series for instance joe reads from
the novel to henry in the opening
episode in season 1 beck and joe refer
to themselves as fitzgerald and his wife
zelda and then there's 40s habit of
calling joe old sport like gatsby does
joe taking on the name nick might
additionally be a subconscious reference
to dr nikki who he framed for beck's
murder and who i think could be coming
back for season 4 which i talk a lot
more about in my season 4 theories video
as matthew waits for theo he reads about
the events in what the media's dubbed
the quinn goldberg butcher house an
article in the real life online women's
magazine the curt reveals that love's
reported murder suicide has inspired
memes art and even a k-pop viral hit
titled pie for me die for me a nod to
part of joe's body being baked in a pie
akin to the infamous human meat pies
made by mrs lovett in the tale of the
cereal killing barber sweeney todd
apparently love's original name for her
bakery was love muffin both a euphemism
and a throwback to how she used to leave
those sweet treats in joe's locker at
naverin muffins yeah i seem to remember
owing you one the article explains that
love wasn't able to clear the rights to
the name which could be a real world in
joke as it is actually the name of a
singles website in real life and
curiously it's also the name of the
antagonist group in disney's animated
phineas and ferb disney should sue these
people the article's accompanying photo
is from love and joe's wedding and its
depiction of a blood covered cake with a
bride murderously bashing the groom from
behind is a humorous call back to kiki's
cupcake order at the top of the episode
can you make two dozen bloody looking
ones by tonight i'm having my true crime
book club over to dish both love and
joe's use of the poison wolf bane on
each other is a twisted reference to the
special love language they created
between themselves in season two i wolf
you i will few too and thanks to valar
mogulus for pointing out that wolf is
also even the brand of their oven which
joe uses to burn love and their home to
the ground and for a full breakdown of
more details you might have missed in
the season 3 finale tap here to watch my
ending explained video or follow the
link in the video description
just before the credits roll in the
first episode a screen appears in honor
of actor mark blum who played mr mooney
joe's surrogate father and bookstore
owner in new york blum sadly died in
march 2020 from complications arising
from covered 19. so what other details
did you notice in season 3 and what were
your favorite moments let me know in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
then a like and a share are hugely
appreciated you can tap left for my full
you playlist including the season 3
ending explained or tap right for my
season 4 theories including whether love
could still be alive thanks for watching
and see you next time yippee kai movie
lovers